mike fires is on the bump wearing the
old kelly green
uniform tops making his sixth start the
leadoff man is david fletcher we're
about ready swung on a fly ball they're
going to get him out cannons and left
coming on about five steps he's there
and he makes the catch and that's the
way our ball game begins and la stella
is coming up fires with a pitch and a
ground ball back at first fair olson has
it flipping to fire his covering and
quickly two away mistell is out 3-1 and
mike trout
is coming up and hit him on the breaking
ball against trout so rendon will bound
with a man on anthony rendon with his
10-game hit streak is really crushing
the baseball
doane hits one back up the middle and
hit streak continues travel advances
second base and stop there put the pair
on with two outs and we'll see what
brian goodwin can do he's down it in
murphy trying to backhand it gets away
from him the wild pitch would put
runners at second and third the base hit
could mean a couple of runs here as the
angels try and get something on the
board with two outs in the first here's
the one-two pitch breakeve swung out of
miss he drops the curve in the dirt and
goodwin strikes out and fires works out
of it andrew heaney on the mound for the
angels tonight start number six of the
year for the angels opening day starting
pitcher simeon leads off for the is
bought over the first against the lefty
andrew heenes and marcus hits it to
center field trout going back still
going back at the track he'll turn and
watch it fly
and simeon hits it out to straight away
center field one-nothing athletics
yes chapman a right-handed hitter and
chapman it's a driving to left going
back goodwin turning around it's over
his head one hopping the wall and
chapman's turning it first he's going to
second with a double and so far andrew
heaney has been no mystery there's
cannon still only one out and the fish
to count us inside he works another walk
and that'll bring up matt olsen as the
a's have two on and one out go to pitch
territory makes the catch and even
though that's it now that's a lot of the
plate on the no two pitch so here's
piscotty now with two outs and runners
at first and second a run in drives on
the left goodwin hustling back and that
is gonna sail over his head and it
bounces away chapman's gonna score
cannon is gonna score in a big two out
two run double for stephen pascotti and
it's to nothing
oh he had an injury last night
he was one of our friends down the left
field line one of the bears who took a
shot to the melon
but
the word is he is okay today in fact
he's here
he's back in the house which is good
tough guy top of the fourth inning
anthony riddeau to lead things off here
comes the next pitch brandon slices one
into right center that's gonna fall in
for a base hit boy his bat is red hot
right now seven for 13 against the a's
this year now albert at the plate breaks
his bad hits with down the left-field
line that is a fair ball brendon heading
to third base he's gonna be stopped
there pujols has himself a double here's
ben boom 3-2
and he walked him now the angels have
the bases loaded and andrewton simmons
will be the hitter swung up popped up
shallow center loriano is going to have
a play ramon coming in makes the catch
and the inning is over and mike escapes
some traffic in the fourth inning this
muncher is over two that's the headline
of course fletcher entered tonight 11
for 28 this year against the a's
that fastball [ __ ] up the right field
toward the corner david fletcher with a
lead-off double how'd he hit that ball
that's over his head it's built higher
judge got on top of it too mike trout
will be the batter with two one nobody
out as the angels trying to get back in
this game down by three trout hits a
high fly ball left field twisting down
the line long run for canada at the
track he's right to the wall comes in a
couple of steps and he makes the catch
and the a's can exhale and crowd just
under it a mile high fly ball to left is
one out two on here's rendon 20 for his
last 39 last 11 games toward the left
side of the base hit past simon fletcher
scores the angels get on the board it's
a three-hit game for rendon two out
double and now matt olson will be the
next batter boy you just want to get
that that offense restarted lifted left
field back on a good one still going
back at the track reaching up over the
shoulder he can't get it scoring his
canna and the a's take a 4-1 lead and
biscotti will stand in stephen it's a
ground ball up the middle and into
center for a base hit that'll score
olson and the a's take a five to one
lead the angels will have mike trout
stepping up with runners everywhere and
two outs broken down roller to the right
shot olson had to go off his club and
trickles into shadow right two runs will
score wow that's a break huge break
horribly misplayed by matt olsen if he
had just gone to the bag it was going to
be handled by chad pinder and it's a
five to three game so here's rendon
who's been on fire fly ball center field
back on it loriano still going back has
a play 10 feet from the track and he
makes the catch and when delkin
preserves the lead and it's a five to
three game and trout's coming up he's
the tying run but now two out in the
eighth three four eleven in his career
against sorya with the home run a good
battle between
sorry and trout with the game on the
line who's going to blink first 3-2
pitch breaking ball ring him up froze
him strike three called perfect pitch
what a job by soria liam hendricks comes
out of the aspen the angels are down to
their final out in this game swung on
fly ball right center lorianna going
back has the plays there in the alley
and he makes the catch once again
henriks does the job they have taken the
first game of the series